- Okay, fine I'll watch it.
- Part of what you have
to factor into is again,
just have to drill down
on what actually happened.
You have a photograph of our
client you know in a building.
- Why, why are you,
why are you admitting that?
You don't have to admit the authenticity.
- Not authorized to be there with.
- Why are you admitting that?
- In what appears to be
a podium or a lectern?
I'm not exactly sure
which one it's called.
- It's a lectern.
- But that's what we have.
- Obviously that presents problems
for you as a defense attorney
in that you have your client
in the building at the time
of the break-ins.
- Yeah I don't know the,
you know how else to explain that
but yeah, that's that's,
that would be a problem.
I'm not a magician and
neither is Mr. Digney.
So yeah, we've got a photograph of our.
- I mean, he's not wrong,
that is a huge friggen problem.
- We've got what appears
to be inside the federal building
or inside the Capitol
with government property.
- Why are you admitting that?
Why are you talking to the press?
Just say no comment,
no comment is always an option.
You have a right to remain silent.
Just like your client,
ah I'm broken.